une vieille grange en pierre qui n'a
rien de musée abrite pourtant des pièces
uniques de l'aviation
comme cette réplique grandeur nature du
fairchild fc2 construit à montréal par
la canadienne veilleuse à partir de 1928
sur le premier avion au canada avec une
cabine chauffée ou sur chris reid
biplace fabriqués à quartier ville ou si
à la fin des années 20 très intéressant
le corps puis
une complice de d'enquêté que d'origine
qui voit beaucoup d'argent maintenant
une dizaine de bénévoles la plupart des
retraités du milieu de l'aviation
s'affairent à restaurer de vieux avions
comme john hoffman sean un ancien pilote
d'air canada avec à son actif fin 2000
heures de vol je suis un pilote retraité
d'air canada à ma retraite depuis dit
certains vip piloter quoi j'ai appris
que l'avion le dc-9 le boeing
767 2 rbds à 70 20
autre appareil unique un blériot qui a
volé à montréal en 1910 le premier avion
qui volait pas dessus molière pour 50
minutes des avions mais aussi d'anciens
simulateur de vol mais çà çà çà frein du
theil ça c'était dans pièces détachées
ses formes pic comme c'est fait dans les
années 40 c'est très intéressant
au musée qui cherche un nouvel
emplacement et qui souhaitent devenir
une référence pour les passionnés de
l'aviation en recherche d'argent pour
monter des fonds pour une expansion un
petit musée consacré à la conservation
de l'histoire aéronautique avec une
attention particulière aux réalisations
québécoises
tout ça grâce à des bénévoles dévoués
issigeac bissonnet à radio canada
s'attendent de bellevue